okay we previously talked a little bit
about how some of the 2017 special
elections that we've seen haven't gone
particularly well for Republicans and we
have more instances of that from
yesterday yesterday was election Tuesday
there were a number of different
primaries and local elections municipal
elections and one of them has caused a
really pathetic situation for the
President of the United States Donald
Trump has been supporting Alabama
Republican Luther Strange in the Alabama
Republican Senate primary yesterday
Luther strange lost to Roy Moore okay
these things happen sometimes people you
support lose all of a sudden shortly
after strange lost Trump's tweets over
the last few days supporting Luther
strange they're just gone they're gone
from Trump's Twitter account now
ProPublica has the deleted tweets which
we can show you Donald Trump tweeting
big election tomorrow in the great state
of Alabama vote for senator Luthor
strange tough-on-crime and border will
never let you down
Trump also tweeting before the election
Luther strange has been shooting up in
the Alabama polls since my endorsement
finished the job vote today for big
Luther and Trump also tweeting Alabama
get out and vote for Luther strange he
has proven to me that he will never let
you down hashtag Mogga
this is not what an adult does right
never mind the President of the United
States and it isn't just the reality
that the tweets are archived and
screenshotted so they don't really go
away when Trump elites them it's that an
adult takes the loss like an adult not
by clearing their tweet history to
pretend that it never happened
and of course Trump doesn't want to be
perceived as backing losers and this is
a part of that right and Trump tweeting
congratulations two more and now says
he's backing more in the general
election but the funniest thing about
deleting tweets supporting Luther
strange is that he did an entire rally
for Luther strange
that's the rally where the entire Colin
Kapernick is a son of a [ __ ] thing
exploded and now all of a sudden he's
deleting a few tweets as if that's going
to cover the tracks of what was clearly
significant support for the guy that did
lose and Trump must know that these
tweets just don't
go away I mean you can screenshot this
stuff but I think that demonstrates that
he really is a sore loser yeah because
it's gonna be more embarrassing for him
to take those down right I don't know I
genuinely don't know and we don't know
if it was Trump himself we took them
down or if it was someone else who
thought hey here's an idea let's get rid
of those but again Trump did the rally
Trump did the rally and it's it's you
you can't cover the tracks and it's such
a childish thing to do and quick note
because I do want to talk about some of
these elections that took place
yesterday Luthor strange was the NRA
endorsed candidate in Alabama and he
lost that's sort of notable although
Moore did have quite a bit of name
recognition in Alabama and there's a
really interesting question about the
deletion of tweets which is should Trump
even be allowed to delete tweets since
they're arguably part of the
presidential record there's a lawsuit
over this right now NPR reported about
this lawsuit recently and this question
of whether Trump can delete tweets is
part of it where NPR said
additionally the lawsuit draws attention
to Trump's use of his personal Twitter
account under the Obama administration
social media posts were included as a
type of communication to be archived
under the presidential Records Act any
of trumps statements made on Twitter are
subject to federal record-keeping and
the lawsuit argues that any deleted
tweets would count as a violation of the
PRA as well and the lawsuit specifically
points to an instance in November when
Donald Trump deleted a message about
meeting with generals at mar-a-lago so
that's interesting and that's going to
be legislated now separately some other
interesting results from election night
last night in one New Hampshire district
a very red district where Republicans
have a two-to-one advantage over
Democrats in terms of voter registration
Democrat Kerry Lerner defeated former
state Rep James head by 39 votes this is
a New Hampshire House seat so it's a
local seat but these are some of the
little indications that are suggesting
we might see a major midterm win for
Democrats at the national level but it's
going to come down to get out the vote
right this was a very narrow victory
two-to-one edge for Republicans over
Democrats in terms of registrations in
this cow
in in this district in New Hampshire 39
votes you can individually flip that
district you can convince 39 people to
go out and vote just by yourself right
so we have to understand how much is at
stake and how important get out the vote
is very very interesting just a little
early sign of what we might start to see
as we're now only I guess 13 months away
from the midterm elections the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad